4 billion dollars in capital investment
anticipated that means thousands and
thousands of good paying jobs
uh alberta treasury branches this week
has estimated that we will see the
highest number of housing starts in
alberta in seven years
the calgary real estate board uh said
that there are very few homes available
on the market in
calgary and that values are now going up
significantly
in this city uh we saw as new data
showing that the number of albertans uh
receiving employment insurance benefits
is down by 55 year over year
and of course we closed out 2021 with
the creation of over 130 000 net new
jobs so all great news i think it's
important to point that out that uh
alberta is has got real economic
momentum
a key part of that of course is our huge
exports particularly to our largest
trading partner the united states
alberta
in 2020 exported 78 billion dollars in
goods and services to our largest
trading partner the year before 2019 our
exports were worth more than a hundred
billion dollars and we believe
pardon me that with the increase in
commodity prices we'll be able to
break that record again and sell the
americans over a hundred billion dollars
worth of alberta produced goods and
services
that export trade with the united states
supports
785 000 jobs in alberta's economy and so
there are very few issues more important
for us than our trading relationship
with the united states but there are
barriers being erected barriers to
pipelines uh of course the veto of the
veto of keystone xl but also the effort
by the state of michigan to decommission
the enbridge line five project and many
other
political and legal battles being led to
landlocked canadian energy and alberta
oil and gas from the united states
we also see growing american
protectionism expressed in areas like of
course softwood lumber the buy america
provisions
and now we see serious emerging
threats to our supply chains our grocer
as we know much of our grocery stores
are stocked by products produced in the
united states
we are seeing huge uh inflation and the
cost of food and many other
basic necessities here in alberta and
across canada
and that situation that bad situation
has been made worse
by the trudeau government's uh reckless
decision to uh impose a quarantine
requirement on unvaccinated truckers
coming from the united states which has
further stressed
supply chains and that will further
create issues around availability of
food essential products pushing up
in prices at the worst possible time of
course the us government has done the
same thing for canadian trucker truckers
traveling south we don't think there's
any
uh compelling public health reason for
this given that there are millions of
canadians with active omicron infections
tens of millions of americans with
active infections the vast majority of
truckers are vaccinated
and the governments had granted a
multi-month uh exemption to this rule we
simply asked them to restore that
exemption i've been on the phone and in
contact this week
with
governors and premiers on this issue and
indeed a number of the governors uh
signaled for me that they were gathering
in washington dc this weekend for the
national governors association annual
meeting i've decided at their prompting
to travel to washington i'll be going
straight there uh following this news
conference
to spend three days in washington dc uh
attending the national governor's
association meeting
meeting with many of the top
leaders and decision makers in the
united states
in
amongst the governors
congressional leaders as well as
potentially people in the u.s
administration
and important stakeholder organizations
like the teamsters
the u.s transport association the us
chamber of commerce
and other organizations stay tuned for
more details
but this is a very important mission
first of all
to seek supporters for our effort to get
the two federal governments to suspend
the application of the quarantine
requirement for truckers to work more
deeply on the many supply chain issues
which are a serious threat to both
economies but also uh to continue our
efforts to fight for market access and
pipelines for canadian for alberta
energy exports to the united states and
to work on other important trade issues
such as the buy america provision and
softwood lumber
our relationship with the united states
is so important that alberta's
government recently announced our plan
to open three additional trade and
investment offices to represent our
vital economic interests in the united
states this
trip this weekend is an important part
of that
another piece of good news before i get
to the covet update and that is
very happy to see that the united nurses
of alberta members have ratified a new
collective bargaining agreement with the
government of alberta i understand 87
of their members voting ratified the
agreement
and let me just say how much all
albertans value and appreciate our
nurses particularly given the huge
stress they've been working under over
the past two coveted years and uh
the we have tremendous professionals
many of them have uh taken on uh
extra shifts uh over and over and over
again
and many of them are struggling with
with burnout because of the the pressure
uh that many have been experiencing for
example in icus and now in emergency
boards in many parts of the problems we
value and appreciate alberta nurses
i believe that this collective
bargaining agreement is a win-win
because it provides for modest
compensation increases
but in line with our need to be fiscally
responsible i think it's a win for
nurses and a win for taxpayers
it ensures that alberta nurses continue
to be the best compensated in canada at
the same time it brings their
compensation closer to the national
average and other provinces
which has always been one of our
objectives
so that we can reallocate more of our
growing health care budget
to
uh delivery and and to address the
historic um
misalignment with other problems is on
labor costs so this i think is an
important is a compromise on both sides
to get to this point um i want to
say thank you to the una for uh
negotiating in good faith and we're very
happy that we could come to
this agreement uh which
ensures continuity of service and
stability amongst our critical workforce
of nurses the agreement also includes
enhanced psychological and mental health
support for nurses and a rural capacity
investment fund
to help incentivize uh
nurses to work in
uh rural communities that sometimes have
challenges uh attracting retaining
healthcare health workers so
very good news there
now finally let me speak to the covet
update and dr hinshaw will follow me uh
i'm pleased to report that we continue
to see good news but we continue to have
reason for caution
uh we continue to see the positivity
rate come down slowly and certainly the
total number of active cases
our waste water data is trending down in
14 of the 18 communities that we monitor
so that continues to be the same cases
last week
and most importantly we've seen
importance of significant declines in
the trends
in calgary and edmonton where omicron
started first
icu numbers for covet have been trending
down as well a little bit
we have today 106
uh coveted patients in intensive care
and 194 patients in intensive care
overall coveted and non-coveted
worth noting that 28
of the 106 uh covet patients in
intensive care are uh incidental covet
cases they tested positive but their
their health they're not there because
of covet
and and so that's context now to compare
this to the peak of the delta wave last
september
at the peak we had uh
257
coveted patients in icu and 317 overall
so today those numbers respectively are
106 and 194 so
um since we seem to be beginning to come
down or destabilize on the icu pressure
it is uh we're grateful to see that
because of the lower severity of
omicron a large part of which is because
of higher vaccination rates
we have seen much much less impact on
our intensive care units
now in terms of non-intensive care
acute care beds
we currently have 1
363 coveted patients
or i should say patients with covid in
hospital 40 of those
are incidental that is to say they were
not admitted to hospital because of
covet but they've subsequently tested
positive um and uh
so
now that is that number has gone up over
the past week or two
and there is real stress in the system
we see particular stress in some of the
large urban uh emergency wards
but the good news in this context is
that
the overall burden of inpatients
in our 100 hospitals across the province
is stable
we've been averaging just under 5300
total uh non-icu inpatients since the
beginning
of january right now we're at
5369
and and so we've had a stable overall
patient population
in the hospital system
over the past month
and i should add that uh that in in an
historic context what we're facing right
now is not unusual
in 2018
uh in january we at peak to 5600
uh in patients in
and that meant 99 of available beds were
full
in 2019 we peaked at 5 400 in patients
and 96
of beds were full
and in 2020 pre-covet we
peaked at 5600 with 89
of beds being uh occupied so right now
we're at 5 369 representing 87 percent
of beds so there's 13 percent of beds
available in patient beds
and now the stats i just cited are for
the 16 largest hospitals in the province
and that represents by far the majority
of inpatient beds and the point is that
that there is significant stress um it
is not
out of line with historic trends at this
time of year
although there is additional stress on
the hospitals because of coveted
protocols
and
there is continued need for albertans to
be
cautious careful please continue to
follow the public health guidelines and
measures uh and uh please if you have
not yet done so get your booster shot
um
i understand that today albert health
services did open the pandemic response
unit in edmonton i described our
preparation for this work last week
so this is a kind of overflow capacity
for uh
patients who are close to being released
from hospital but they may need some
ongoing monitoring and some ongoing uh
health support uh we have not yet
been in a position where we had to open
the pandemic response unit in calgary
and finally on schools
out of the some 2400
k-12 schools in alberta uh currently 25
have moved to online instruction uh so
that's about one percent of the over 2
400 schools in alberta once again thank
you to uh students most importantly uh
the teachers uh parents and everybody in
the education system for their care and
diligence uh during what has been a
challenging time
i'm uh looking forward to taking
questions afterwards but now i'll invite
dr hinshaw for her remarks
thank you premier and good afternoon
everyone
before i get to the latest numbers i
want to clarify what the isolation
requirements currently are in alberta
and when they begin as i've heard some
questions on this topic
if you have covid the greatest
transmission risk is in the few days
before and after symptoms start
but it is still possible for some people
to transmit the virus and infect others
for up to 10 days
that is why if you are not fully
immunized you must isolate at home and
away from others
for the full 10 days
if you share a home with others you
should isolate away from the rest of the
household and at minimum should wear a
well-fitting medical or three-layer
cloth mask if you were in the same room
as others at any time
if you were fully immunized with two or
three doses you must isolate away from
others for at least five days from the
day you were first symptomatic or tested
positive
that is considered day zero
on day six after the onset of symptoms
counting from that day zero
or
the the sixth day after a positive test
result
if your symptoms have resolved you're
able to leave your home but must
complete the rest of the ten days of
isolation
by wearing at minimum a well-fitting
medical or three-layer cloth mask at all
times
this means that in this time period you
are not able to remove your mask to eat
or drink with or near others
this is important to mitigate the
transmission risk in this second part of
the 10-day period
after that full 10 days have passed you
no longer have any specific isolation or
masking requirements over and above the
public health measures in place
i also want to provide some clarity for
albertans who have recently tested
positive for covid19 on when they might
need to contact their family physician
this will help save time for those with
covid and reduce unnecessary calls to
busy clinics
if you have a positive test result you
do not need to contact your family
doctor with the results unless you are
at high risk or experiencing moderate
illness or symptoms
if you're not sure what level of risk
you're at the alberta medical
association has a reference document on
their website that can help you assess
this
if your risk is moderate to high
you should contact your doctor's office
and advise them of your situation so
they can help determine the best
treatment path for you
if you're in this group and want to
share your rapid test results with your
physician you can complete the form
available on alberta.ca and submit that
along with a photo of your rapid test to
the clinic
this reporting is optional but may be
important or helpful to some individuals
i've also heard that some albertans
think they may need a doctor's note when
they have covid to be eligible for
certain benefits or for sick time at
work
however in most cases you do not need
one
if you are applying for the canada
recovery sick benefit or the canada
recovering caregiving benefit a note is
not required as long as you meet the
eligibility criteria
if you contracted covet 19 in your
workplace as a result of your regular
job duties you may be eligible for
coverage and support through the wcb
they accept a positive pcr or rapid test
result or a doctor's diagnosis as part
of their claim process
so a doctor's note is not required if
you have a positive test result
due to the rampant spread of omicron we
ask employers not to require individuals
with mild symptoms to get a covid19 test
or doctor's note to be eligible for sick
time off work
instead please support sick employees at
this time of high transmission to stay
home with no testing or doctor's note
requirements
some patients have requested a doctor's
letter to help facilitate some aspect of
domestic or international travel
but doctor's notes are generally not
required or warranted for travel
purposes
it's most important that anyone planning
to travel is fully vaccinated and has
proof of their vaccines
i hope this information is helpful for
those who might be wondering when to
call their doctor about covid
turning to today's numbers
over the last 24 hours we have
identified
3218 new cases of covid19 and completed
about
9350 tests our positivity rate for lab
confirmed tests is about 34.7 percent
as you know due to the rapid rise of the
omicron variant we adjusted pcr testing
eligibility a few weeks ago to ensure
those who have clinical risk factors for
severe outcomes and those who live or
work in high risk settings can get
tested and receive their results in a
timely manner
we continue to monitor this approach
closely and evaluate the capacity of our
labs
at this point we are able to meet the
demand for all these high-risk
individuals in a timely way and we have
the opportunity today to introduce a
small change to pcr testing eligibility
effective immediately children under the
age of two are again able to get tested
for covid19 through ahs assessment
centers
this is a pragmatic approach since rapid
tests are currently not licensed for use
in children under the age of two
the ability to be tested affects the
length of their required isolation due
to covet as these children are also not
eligible for vaccination
if a child is symptomatic and tests
positive for covid19 they are required
to isolate for 10 days
if they are symptomatic but test
negative they can leave isolation once
their symptoms resolve
given this requirement and the link to
test results we want to ease the burden
on parents by allowing them to access
pcr testing again since rapid testing at
home is not recommended for this age
group
parents and guardians can book
appointments online for children under
two years with symptoms
using the ahs assessment tool or by
calling 8-1-1
for older children who have symptoms
rapid tests can be used which is why the
change today is only for those under age
2.
sadly i must announce today that 14 new
deaths have been reported to alberta
health over the last 24 hours
as always i extend my sympathies to
their families
and to all those grieving the loss of
anyone they loved no matter the cause
between the post-holiday lull and the
cold dark days january can be a
difficult month
that was true in a typical year before
we had to contend with covert 19 and the
omicron variant
combined with those factors though this
january may feel more challenging than
ever
as we near the two-year milestone of the
pandemic i know people are experiencing
a lot of complex emotions
and many albertans are struggling
whether it's from being infected with a
virus the stresses of upended routines
or struggling to see when we can return
to a more normal way of life many of us
are having a difficult time
for many practicing self-care strategies
such as maintaining
exercise eating well using relaxation
techniques or relying on loved ones
is enough however if you or someone you
know
finds these struggles are overwhelming
or interfering with your daily life i
urge you to seek mental health supports
free non-judgmental help is available
for anyone who needs it a list of
comprehensive resources is available at
alberta dot ca slash mental health
no matter what you are struggling with i
want you to know you are not alone
there are supports and resources out
there for you and many other people are
going through similar challenges
in the fall findings from a national
survey were released that indicated one
in four canadians aged 18 and older
screened positive for symptoms of
depression anxiety or post-traumatic
stress disorder in spring of 2021
this is up from one in five in the fall
of 2020
these symptoms undermine an individual's
well-being and quality of life the good
news is that there are mental health
supports to help all of us through
as i've said before we must remember
that the enemy we are fighting is
covid19 not each other
now more than ever it is essential to
intentionally employ compassion both for
ourselves and those around us
we don't know the situations or
challenges our neighbors are facing but
we can safely assume that things aren't
easy
we need to make time to care for
ourselves and those around us
kind gestures can go a long way in
helping each other
i ask all of us to create safe spaces
for our own and others emotions given
the burden of grief that so many are
carrying
each one of us matters and our actions
make a difference
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thank you
that concludes the formal portion of
today's media availability we'll now
move over to a q a uh since there are no
journalists here in person move right
over the phones just reminded callers to
limit yourself to one question one
follow-up as well as try to keep your
questions as brief as possible with that
operator can you please connect our
first call
thank you matt woodman ctv
hi there dr hinshaw the premier
explained that it was necessary to open
the pandemic response unit in edmonton i
was hoping to explain why that was
necessary and how many patients are
currently staying there
unfortunately i don't have the details
of the acute care burdens or the
shifts of patients in terms of where
they're being cared for what we do know
is that the burden of disease that
omicron has caused
is straining the capacity of the system
in particular in some urban areas and
that this is meaning that there are
extra spaces that needed to be opened up
the specifics of how many patients and
how that change and and shift is
happening
unfortunately i don't have that
information
and i'll just add i'm afraid i don't
have the exact number of patients in
there right now
but this is something that we've been
preparing for for a long time we
signaled last week that ahs was taking
the next steps to prepare the pandemic
response units should they be necessary
uh to add some additional overflow
capacity as i pointed out in my remarks
we are at 87
of our inpatient bed capacity through
the entire 100 bed sorry 100 hospital
network of alberta health services uh
which and at 87 percent uh we are at a
lower uh percentage of of uh capacity
that is typically the top of the case at
this time of year however uh as dr
incheon just said some of our uh
large urban hospitals are under
particular stress that's where a lot of
the patients end up getting transferred
to and so we're closer to 98 99
capacity in some of the large urban
hospitals
um
the
uh
as you know
one of the challenges with covet
patients whether they are hospitalized
for or with coped whether they are
primary or incidental
in terms of cov19 is they all require
additional space for isolation protocols
and that just takes up more space more
rooms in the hospital more inpatient bed
space
and so the prus
are are there to kind of accommodate uh
for that that factor of requiring a bit
more space to spread people out given
isolation protocols within the hospitals
um
the prus as i understand i've been
briefed by ahs the uh you know initially
initially uh
18 months ago we were looking at these
facilities potentially for overflow
intensive care capacity for ventilated
beds and
intensive care
that is not the need at this point
to the in fact we're dealing sort of
with the other end of the spectrum of
severity for hospitalized patients
it will these prus will largely be used
for patients who are close to being
released from hospital but require some
additional monitoring before that
happens so it's uh it's a it's a
strategy to create a little bit more
space and flexibility within the system
okay and matt do you have a follow-up
today
i do uh we're hearing about high numbers
of cases in some long-term care
facilities is there anything new being
done to protect residents from covet
spreading within these settings uh and
is there any additional supports for
these centers
i think dr h
sure so we've been working with
stakeholders in the continuing care
sector meeting regularly with operators
to understand the impacts
we know that in continuing care the
goal that we have had for
many many months now is to try to
balance all of the health needs of those
residents we know that residents need
the protection from covet 19 infection
we also know that they need to have
connections with people that they care
about so that they're not feeling
isolated so visitor restrictions we know
when we put those in place previously
had a significant negative impact on
mental health and well-being of people
who lived in these settings we also know
that residents who live in these
settings need to have people who can
meet all of their care needs and
so making sure that there are enough
staff in a time where there are lots of
individuals who are falling sick and
need to be off work so we are working to
try to balance all of those care needs
for people in these settings the good
news is that so far we're seeing the
hospitalization
and
severe outcome ratios of the cases in
these settings as being much lower than
we've seen in previous waves however we
are working as
hard as we can with those operators with
our partners with alberta health
services to make sure that supports are
provided
when cases are identified
to minimize spread unfortunately in some
cases we have seen larger outbreaks
but again these are all the factors that
we're trying to balance the
emotional supports the connection with
people that these residents care about
the coveted protections and the care
needs and uh we will continue to do so
thanks very much dr himself operator can
you please put through our next call
thank you rick bell calgary son
good afternoon premier and dr hinshaw uh
for the premier first question is um
what do you say to those people which by
the way includes some of your mlas and
supporters but
people generally who when they hear
this evolving good news
would like to see an end to vaccine
passports not just
as it relates to truckers but just
generally they'd like to see that happen
some of them want to see it happen now
but others want to see it happen at
least in the very near future
and
forever and related to that they they
see that as just the first step towards
a fairly
soon maybe a month two months i have no
idea uh maybe st patrick's day um
lifting lifting of restrictions
generally so the question is basically
there are people who want
fairly soon the vaccine passports for
everybody to be lifted and then not you
know maybe weeks later or whatever when
how do you see that picture shape
shaping up from those numbers that
you've given us
well i'm one of the people that wants to
see an end to the restriction exemption
program and as quickly as possible
but that's not right now rick we are
continuing to see
uh upward movement in our uh
inpatient bed hospitalization pressure
from covet 19
and we're at in fact the highest point
in the two years in terms of people in
hospital uh with covid so
while there is some good news uh that
can be encouraging for all of us
now is not the right time
to be relaxing measures when the health
hospitals under are under so much
pressure
but
i very much hope that we can move
towards widespread relaxation of public
health measures including the proof of
vaccination program
in the foreseeable future
once we start to see the pressure in
hospitals trend down
and
we are going to make that decision based
on data based on what we're seeing in
other
jurisdictions that hit omicron before
alberta
and of course we'll take very seriously
all of the public health advice that we
receive
so
rick i would say i i understand people's
impatience i share it
uh i i did say when we brought in the
proof of vaccination program back in
early september
that
i did not foresee it going past the
first quarter of 2022 that would be the
end of march
um and i am hopeful based on
the trends we are beginning to see here
we've seen elsewhere
that uh we'll be able to consider
lifting that and most other public
health measures um uh well before that
so i'm not going to start guessing about
when which it's too early to do so i
just i say to people who are impatient i
am too i get it but uh let's
let's just you know after a couple years
of this thing
just keep our eye on the ball
have the backs of the people in our
hospitals
let's not
uh start uh removing measures that that
could trip us back into higher
transmission hospitalizations when the
hospitals are already under so much
pressure so that day you're talking
about is coming
um i'm pretty confident it will come in
before the end of march uh and i hope it
comes
and i'll just tell you this we will uh
eliminate
the restriction exemption program
as soon as it is safe to do so
okay thank you premier rick do you have
a follow-up today
yes uh i do it's it's cobit-related uh
and it's related to the convoy uh the
trucker convoy uh which you've talked
about before now we all know what the
stated purpose of the convoy is so i'm
not going to ask you
what you've already expressed about your
view of the convoy
but
do you see
this protest as also having
uh a broader and deeper message to
the federal government to canadia to all
canadian politicians
and to other decision makers
that this sort of grassroots
uh cross-country
convoy is happening is there some
message that you think political figures
and other
perhaps non-elected decision makers
should take seriously from watching this
well first rick i think it's important
to say that we should all be grateful
for truckers
they keep our
grocery store shelves stocked day in and
day out they have uh while a lot of
people were sheltering at home over much
of the past two years they were out
there on the roads in good weather and
bad um keeping us and our whole society
and economy rolling so thank you to the
truckers and uh i
i i think it's important to to to
acknowledge that secondly um rick
everybody has the right uh for
democratic and peaceful protest in our
country
and we should be respectful of that
uh i agree with those who are protesting
the
uh i think pointless quarantine rule
being applied to cross-border truckers
that's why i'm going to washington dc
today
to raise this with top american leaders
and i do hope that those organizing the
convoy do everything they can to make
sure that it's safe
uh i hope that they disassociate
themselves with anybody
in the convoy who might have extreme or
hateful views but i acknowledge that you
know in any big social movement there
are going to be some people with fringe
views
uh you know whenever the ndp shows up at
some of those uh so-called environmental
protests uh in the front of the
legislature
there are people who hold what i would
call eco-terrorist views i don't see the
media running all over their social
media accounts trying to throw a
spotlight on them and i don't see the
ndp disassociating themselves with
everybody who might show up with uh
with extreme views at a protest
now um rick one thing that really
concerns me is
the divisive comments
of justin trudeau where he said
he characterized all of the thousands of
people involved in this
as uh
he said we should not tolerate them
and he said that they're
they are holding unacceptable views that
don't represent the views of canadians
well
whether he agrees with them or not they
are canadians
and they're entitled to hold their views
about covet policy
and they're entitled to express them
safely and lawfully
this is the same prime minister
who famously said about canadian
citizens convicted of terrorism that
quotes a canadian is a canadian as a
canadian
well if he's willing to defend convicted
terrorists
as canadians
why is he condemning
thousands of people who feel strongly
uh i i think
the prime minister's job is to unite
canadians not divide them i think his
divisive approach to this
makes the situation a whole lot worse as
does his quarantine policy on
cross-border truckers which is forcing
up food prices
and making life even more difficult
thank you premier
unfortunately we're on a bit of a tight
deadline today to uh to get to
the airport so we we might only have
time for one more question we'll try to
squeeze another one in if we can but
with that operator please put through
our next call
kaiser city news
hey good afternoon thanks for taking my
question not really sure whether uh
dr henshaw could answer this or the
premiere but
wondering if you have someone who
refused to get the vaccine who meets the
criteria to get the uh pac-slovad pill
versus someone else who could benefit
from it who has gotten their shot
assuming they both have similar risk
statuses and
are in similar age groups which one of
those two people would be prioritized in
uh in
alberta well dr dr insha that's a
medical question so over to you
the current eligibility criteria include
all those who are either immunized or
unimmunized who have a significant
immune compromising condition such as
somebody who's under treatment for
cancer
someone who's taking medication for an
autoimmune condition that's suppressing
their immune system it also includes
those who don't have the protection of
vaccines who have other conditions
such as diabetes for example
what the protocol is is that as
individuals become identified as having
covid19
they're referred through the system to
determine if they meet the eligibility
criteria they then have a conversation
with a clinician who can determine based
on that particular individual's needs
and
clinical conditions
and their context which of the two
treatment options so we do have paxlovid
we also have cetrova satrovamab the
monoclonal antibody treatment that we've
had available for several months
and which of those two treatments would
be recommended for that individual
there is at this time of course a
limited supply but as people become
eligible they will be offered that
treatment
and if they fall into any of those
eligibility criteria the
that treatment will be offered as long
as it is available and hopefully we will
be able to access more supply in the
coming weeks and months what we do know
again is that we have both cetrovamab
and paxlovid
and so far in terms of the demand for
cetrovamab we have had sufficient to
meet the demand for people who qualify
so it would be my hope that that same
would be true now that we have this
additional medication to add to
that
suite of options for early treatment
but i would of course always encourage
those who have not yet received the
benefit that vaccines provide to take
advantage of that because that is the
best and safest way of protecting
yourself from severe outcomes of covid
okay and safe do you have a follow-up
today
uh no i'll uh let another journalist ask
a question
okay thanks very much operator can you
please connect our last call of the day
thank you one moment
chris f ctb calgary
all right thank you premier i'm just
curious i talked to a few community
associations and rinks today
who said that um
they're spending five six seven grand a
month
on people whose job is just to check
passports and that grant that rap grant
of two thousand dollars ran out a long
time ago do you anticipate more grants
going towards them or any other small
businesses since this program is still
going
uh
we'll take a look at that but i hope
that won't be necessary in the
foreseeable future as i said earlier i
very much hope that we can wind up the
restriction exemption program in the
foreseeable future we just need to start
to see
a sustained decline in hospitalizations
uh we'll keep our eye on that and the
data will we won't act until it's safe
to do so but i would just ask them and
the businesses who have to do this i
would let me just say thank you to all
of them uh businesses and non-profits
alike community organizations i know
it's been a it's been a pain it's been a
hassle
but
they've been doing their part to help to
keep uh the families going to their uh
community ranks safe
and uh so really want to thank them for
the the effort and sacrifice they've
made but uh but hopefully this will be
behind us uh soon enough
and chris do you have a uh follow-up to
wrap things up today
yeah thank you i'm just looking for a
big clarification here earlier in the
the news or i thought you'd said that
the hospitalization rates were down a
bit
we've had peaks in the past two years
that were higher than now but i
understand dr hinshaw that the strain is
is quite high right now and also if you
just clarify that and also with all the
you know our our death count seems to be
just the numbers seem so much higher now
each day than they were before is that
really indicative of a of a pandemic
that's kind of slowing down
well first of all with respect to every
death of course is a terrible sadness uh
and uh my condolences go out to all of
those who who have passed away from
covet and from all other
health conditions over uh the past two
years and everybody else impacted
indirectly in the healthcare system
through post moments of surgeries and
and all of this has been
incredibly difficult and in some cases
very tragic for families
we can continue to expect to see
regrettably hospitalizations and
fatalities as a result of this virus
and uh when you're dealing with such
large numbers as we are
probably hundreds of thousands of
albertans who currently have active
infections millions of canadians
um and even though the percentages of
those infected
who
um
pass away from
omicron are much lower than the
percentages who have
died from earlier variants of covet 19
it's still
uh unfortunately
going to affect some people uh in with
the most severe outcomes both
hospitalizations and fatalities
uh in terms of the the numbers what i'm
telling you is that our total overall
inpatient
beds
uh number of inpatients i should say in
our
100 hospital network has been fairly
constant through the month of january
averaging between
200 and 5 300 well we have about
6 400 beds available so system wide
we're operating at 87
of capacity
and that is uh lower than is typically
the case uh in pre-covered years
uh we have seen
um
at the peak for we've seen higher
numbers often uh overall in the in the
top 16 hospitals system capacity often
peaking out in the high 90s so look i'm
not for a moment diminishing the stress
that the hospitals are under
it is real it's added to by the
complexity of caring for coveted
patients with isolation protocols and
additional ppe and um
and medical protocols
i think we are seeing particular stress
on uh certain urban emergency wards
right now as well and we have and the
biggest challenge is
uh the exhaustion of our healthcare
workforce our frontline workers who have
been through much through so much stress
and many of whom i think about five
percent of whom right now at any given
time
are
having to stay away from work because
they've tested positive
so
all of these things combined are adding
up to to very significant stress
my point is that
fortunately overall we are seeing uh the
the system coping
um and we're starting to see a i believe
at least a stabilization if not a
decline uh in intensive care numbers and
that's really you know in in earlier
waves our greatest anxiety was around
the scarcity
of intensive care beds and the pressure
on those wards because you know for
obvious reasons and and uh thankfully we
are not experiencing that at least so
far in the omicron wave
all right thanks folks that's wrapped
things up for today
thank you
you